my biggest strategy for dealing with  criticism and negative feedback  or people who are trying to get you is  just empathy  it's just empathy i will tell myself  that this person is in a lot of pain  this person  hates their life they don't know me and  they're taking it out on me  empathy i try to understand where  they're coming from if it's somebody  that you're dealing with regularly if  that's your mom or or that's an aunt or  somebody  you know in your family your grandfather  then  you already know going in that that's  going to be a problem you already know  going in that they're going to criticize  you for something  and so you can work your way through  empathy  ahead of time when you're about to talk  to them and they're going to ask you  about your  your relationship or your business or  your career and they're judging you  understand that they probably love you  right they probably love you your mom  probably loves you  she just has a different view of success